[Música]
Bienvenidos en la sandino desde Ecuador
en esta emisión hablaremos el primer
juicio político en contra de un
presidente en su historia democrática
que mantiene expectativa a todo un país
conoceremos Por qué la oposición asegura
que el presidente de la república es
responsable político del supuesto delito
de peculado los argumentos del gobierno
para desestimar una eventual crisis
democrática en Ecuador que puede
terminar en una destitución del
presidente de la república también
explicaremos Cuáles son las razones que
han llevado al gobierno de Guillermo
lasso a enfrentar cuatro intentos de
sacarlo del poder en dos años de gestión
y para terminar comentaremos los
antecedentes históricos que
caracterizaron la inestabilidad
democrática de Ecuador la apreciación de
los ciudadanos en las calles y los
posibles escenarios para un gobierno
caracterizado por la confrontación
política un juicio político contra un
presidente en Ecuador un hecho sin
precedente en su historia democrática la
acusación se basa en la supuesta omisión
del mandatario a la firma de un contrato
entre la flota petrolera ecuatoriana
Lope p y el servicio de transporte de
crudo amazonas tanker y denuncias de
corrupción a empresas del estado que
ocasionaron un perjuicio de 6 millones
de dólares
durante 30 días una comisión legislativa
convocó a interpelantes y Defensores
para recomendar o archivar el informe
que sustenta el cometimiento del
supuesto delito de peculado estoy
convencida que el presidente de la
república es responsable político y
además no solamente político también
estoy convencida que el presidente de la
república también debe ser sancionado
penalmente y le he puesto una denuncia
penal en la fiscalía general del estado
por peculado la comisión legislativa
encargada de documentar las pruebas en
contra de Guillermo lasso no alcanzó los
votos para aprobar el informe que
recomienda no enjuiciar al presidente de
la república el texto no vinculante
asegura que los contratos referidos
fueron firmados en fechas distintas a la
gestión de lasso serán los votos en la
asamblea nacional la que definan el
destino del presidente ecuatoriano el
gobierno asegura que no existe un
supuesto delito de peculado como lo
indican los cuatro asambleístas
interpelantes en la asamblea nacional
para el coordinador de la bancada
parlamentaria del gobierno Fernando
flores las acusaciones carecen de
sustento jurídico lo primero es que se
ha hablado un contrato del año 2018
cuando Guillermo lasso ASUME la
presidencia en 2021 es decir tres años
antes del ser presidente de la república
lo segundo es que los elementos de este
contrato en el año 2022 que se
establecieron sobre el peculado y que
fue renovado el mismo se caen en el
instante en que la contraloría y la
procuraduría de este país establecen en
un documento un elemento de que no se
mantuvo el contrato no se dio
continuidad y no se dio renovación la
asamblea nacional de Ecuador concentra
al menos cuatro fuerzas políticas que
definirán el peso de los votos unes que
agrupa a los asambleístas afines al
expresidente Rafael Correa Busca la
destitución de Guillermo lasso y
convocar a elecciones anticipadas el
partido social cristiano se pronunció
por la destitución y la sucesión del
poder en el vicepresidente de la
República mientras que izquierda
democrática indígena pachacuti no le
conviene la disolución de la asamblea
Ecuador estuvo marcado por la
inestabilidad política durante años
específicamente desde 1996 hasta el año
2005 tres presidentes preguntes rucados
en el país en ese periodo a partir del
2008 se aprobó la figura constitucional
de la destitución presidencial y la
disolución de la asamblea nacional a
partir del 2008 el Ecuador Tuvo una
nueva constitución esta Constitución
permite entre otras cosas que la figura
de la destitución presidencial sea parte
del contenido constitucional la figura
de la denominada muerte Cruzada esto es
la de solución la disolución por una
sola vez de la asamblea y del ejecutivo
para convocar a nuevas elecciones es una
figura novísima de a partir del año 2008
el juicio político en contra de
Guillermo lasso coincide con la elección
de nuevas autoridades del parlamento y
del partido pachakuti la captación de
escaños y autoridades definirán la
inclinación de fuerzas en la asamblea
nacional las elecciones presidenciales
del año 2025 también son vistas como un
escenario que definirá el futuro de
Ecuador pero Cuáles son las causas que
originaron el juicio político en el país
hay una fuerte hegemonía de la
Revolución ciudadana el expresidente de
correr es muy fuerte alrededor del 30%
del electorado todavía confía Y eso ha
generado una oposición muy fuerte al
gobierno del presidente lasso eso por un
lado pero por otro lado Me parece que
hay errores de de fondo del del propio
gobierno ha demostrado poca capacidad de
administrar el estado poca capacidad de
gestión el Ecuador es paradójico en ese
sentido porque ha mejorado mucho en su
rendimiento macroeconómicos la deuda
pública descendido de forma importante
se ha logrado una estabilidad financiera
del del sector público fundamentalmente
pero eso no se observa en el gasto
social
Guillermo lazo inició su mandato con una
aprobación del 70% hace dos años cifra
que se revirtió y ahora la tiene en
contra la demanda de seguridad el
desempleo y la economía le están pasando
factura a la clase política en las
calles y los Ecuatorianos están
exigiendo un cambio no es la solución
pero tampoco vamos a estar igual que
ahora creo yo o sea cualquiera que sea
el cambio yo creo que sea de ser algo
ventajoso para el pueblo quiero decir el
pueblo está acá el pueblo ecuatoriano
está careciendo de trabajo salud
seguridad
la situación económica creo que de la
mayor parte de los Ecuatorianos
está
muy baja ante un eventual destitución
del presidente de la república la
sucesión del poder recaerá sobre el
vicepresidente Alfredo borrero quien
asumiría el cargo al menos de que lazo
aplique la disolución del parlamento o
muerte Cruzada y se convoque a nuevas
elecciones generales anticipadas en
manos de 92 votos equivalentes a la
mayoría hasta la decisión de la salida
de lazo de la presidencia hasta aquí
esta edición de enlace andino desde
Ecuador les invito a seguir con la
programación de France 24 en español
Gracias por acompañarnos hasta la
próxima